let's make our circle a little bit more
complicated now so let's say I have a
battery again and let me do it in a
different color just for a variety
that's the positive terminal that's the
negative terminal they have this perfect
conductor let's say I have one resistor
I have another resistor and I don't know
just for fun let's throw in the third
resistor and we know of course that the
convention is that the current flows
from positive to negative that that's
the flow of the current and remember
current is just the rate of change or is
just the charge that flows per unit of
time right or the speed of the charge
flow but we know of course that in
reality what is happening if there is
any such thing as reality is that we
have a bunch of electrons here that
because of this voltage across across
the battery terminals these electrons
want to really badly get to the positive
terminal and the higher the voltage the
more that they really want to get to
this positive terminal so what's going
to happen in this circuit actually let
me label everything so let's say let's
call this R 1 let's call this R 2 let's
call this R 3 now the first thing I want
you to realize is that between elements
that the voltage is always constant why
is that well we assume that this is a
perfect conductor let's say this this
little segment right here right and so
it's a perfect conductor well let's
let's look at this end so you have all
these electrons this is a perfect
conductor so there's nothing stopping
these electrons from just distributing
themselves over over this wire so you
can almost you know before you encounter
a an element in the circuit before you
encountered device whatever you want to
call that you could view this ideal
conducting wire just from a schematic
point of view as an extension of the
negative terminal and similarly you can
view this wire right here this part of
the wire as an extension of the positive
terminal and the reason why I want to
say that is because it actually turns
out that it doesn't matter if you
measure the voltage here so let's say if
I take them if I take a measure of the
voltage across those two terminals using
what
we call a voltmeter and I'll I'll later
do a whole video on how volt meter's
work but remember when we measure
voltage we have to we have to measure it
at two points and why is that because
voltage is a potential difference it's
not some kind of absolute number it's a
difference between essentially how bad
do electrons want to get from here to
here so we measured the voltage between
those two points it would be the exact
same thing as if we measure the voltage
between these two points theoretically
as we know no wires really have no
reason to resistivity all wires have a
little bit but when we draw these
schematics we assume that all of that
the wires are perfect conductors and all
the resistance takes place in the
resistor so that's the first thing I
want you to realize and it makes things
vary so for example everywhere along
this wire this part of the wire the
voltage is constant everywhere or along
this wire the voltage is constant so
that's the first thing I wanted you to
realize let me erase some of this
because I don't want this to get too
messy too messy let me erase this that's
a big important realization when you
later become an electrical engineer and
have much harder problems to solve let
me erase all of this let me erase all of
that let me draw a redraw that because
we can't have that gap there because if
there was that gap current wouldn't flow
and that's actually well I'll draw later
and how you could draw a switch but a
switch is essentially a gap it looks
like a gap in the circuit that you can
open or close right because if you open
it no current will flow if you close a
carnal flow okay so you know now know
that the voltage between devices is
constant the other thing I want to
convince you is that the current through
this entire circuit is constant and that
applies to any circuit in series now
what do I mean by series series just
means that everything in the circuit is
after one another right if we take the
convention we say current flows in this
direction will hit this resistor then
the next resistor then the next resistor
at no point does the circuit branch off
and you know has to choose whether do I
want to go down path a or path B so this
circuit is completely in series and
there's a couple ways I can convince you
that the current but let's call this
let's call the current here let's call
this current here I 1
let's call this current here I - let's
call this card here I three I could draw
another one here I three in a couple of
ways that can convince you that I 1
equals I 2 I 3 1 is I could just say if
you experimentally tried it out using an
ammeter which measures current you would
see that they are identical but the
other way to think about it and this
would this time I'm going to actually
talk about the electrons so let's talk
about things going in this direction is
okay so these electrons through this
wire they can go as fast as they want to
go or I don't know the speed of light
are close to the speed of light since
they have very very very low mass and
then we'll go into relativity one day
but once they get to this resistor they
start bumping into things and they slow
down this resistor is a bit of a
bottleneck right so as fast as they're
traveling here they have to slow down
here and if they slow down here they
have to slow down here because if they
kept going super fast here and then they
slowed down here then they would start
building up here and that just doesn't
make sense that because there we know
that they're evenly spread out etc and
similarly you know they might exit this
resistor at a certain speed and then
slow down even further as they bump into
resistors here but if they're going down
if they're going even slower at this
point then there would be a bottleneck
here so this so essentially they would
have to go at that rate throughout the
whole thing
and another way to think about it is the
resistance the resistance is kind of a
probabilistic thing I don't know when
you think on a macro level we say oh it
has is resistant to just slows it down
but the longer there's a resistor it
increases the probability that some of
the electrons are going to bump into
something and create a little bit of
heat and etc etc so when you put
resistors in series what you're actually
doing is increasing the probability that
more electrons will bump into more
things right say there's an electronic
travel say somehow you know through
freak luck
it doesn't bump into anything as it goes
here so it's going really fast but it
bumps in something here right it only
increases it probably something bumps
into it so there's a bunch of ways you
can think about and I encourage you you
know let me know if there's other ways
that help you but the current through
this entire series circuit is constant
now if we say that what else can we say
well if the current here let's say the
current through here is i1 if the
current through here is i1 what is going
to be the voltage if I measured it from
here to here what is this voltage here
alright I measured with a voltmeter well
v1 is going to be equal to i1 times r1 I
know I put in audits and whatnot and I I
1 times r1 right and similarly if I
measure the voltage from here to here
that voltage is going to be equal to i2
times r2 let's say that this is where I
3 is so the voltage if I were to measure
it from here to here oh boy my phone is
ringing it always gets me while I'm
concentrating I'll answer it's my my-y
phone she'll probably mind that I didn't
answer it but anyway so if we look at
the the voltage from here to here is
going to be i3 i3 times r3 so what we
see is is that the voltage across the
entire circuit which I can write as V
total is going to be equal to the
potential drops the total potential drop
across each of these devices so the way
to think about it is is that well let's
think about the electrons the electrons
here they really want to get here
but after they've bumped around a little
bit and they get here the they've
experienced some potential drop so the
electrons here actually the electrons
here are a little bit less eager to get
here and then once they've gone through
here maybe they're just tired of bumping
around so much and once they're here
they're a little bit less ly eager to
get here so there's a voltage drop
across each device right so the total
voltage is equal to the voltage drop
across each of the devices and let's go
back to the convention and let's say
that the current is going in that
direction
the total voltage drop is equal to v1
plus v2 plus v3 so the total voltage
drop is equal to i1 r1 plus i2
our two plus i3 r3 and what's the total
voltage drop well that's equal to the
total current through the whole system
I total write or the you know the we
just call it I times the total
resistance right is equal to I 1 R 1
plus I 2 R 2 plus I 3 R 3
well we know that all the eyes are the
same hopefully you can take it as a as
you know just conceptually it makes
sense to you that the current through
the entire circuit will be the same so
all of these eyes are the same so we can
just cancel them out right divide both
sides by that I we assume it's nonzero
so we i-i-i-i and then we have that the
total resistance of the circuit is equal
to R 1 plus R 2 plus R 3 so when you
have resistors in series like this the
total resistance of the their combined
resistance is just equal to their sum
and that was just a very long-winded way
of explaining something very similar
simple and I'll do an example let's say
that this voltage is I don't know let's
say it's let's say it's 20 volts let's
say resistor 1 is is 2 ohms let's say
resistor 2 is 3 ohms and let's say
resistor 3 is I don't know 5 ohms so
what is the total resistance through
this circuit well the total resistance
is 2 ohms plus 3 ohms plus 5 ohms so
it's equal to 10 ohms so R is it total
resistance is equal to 10 ohms so if I
were to ask you what is the current
going through this circuit well the
total resistance is 10 ohms we know that
we know Ohm's law voltage is equal to
current times resistance the voltage is
just equal to 20 20 is equal to the
current times 10 ohms right we just
added the resistances divide both sides
by 10 you get the current is equal to 2
amps or 2 coulombs per second so what
what seemed like a very long-winded
explanation actually results in
something that's very very very easy to
apply when resistors in series we just
add
I'm up I will see you in the next video